[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now if you don't know this is of course
a segment where viewers try to find
mistakes that we've made on our show so
far there have been many challengers and
this is shocking no winners I just don't
make mistakes yeah doesn't happen so
tonight this is true a fan named Iona in
Finland or Yana thinks that he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
comedy bit I did last week with Larry
King
here's his video explanation hi Conan
younger from Finland here you need to
sketch above Larry King up in the
rafters I was wondering about this Larry
whose name is written on the beam over
there right there and a black pen
Humphrey Bogart so I have to look it up
and this came up notice that there's no
cross line on letter T however this one
does so I'm a little suspicious but
that's all peace and love what the hell
was that
what is that I've been to Finland that's
not how they blow a kiss they go and
then woo and like be a fake listen it's
Yona that's your real name I love your
people okay I love your country but man
are you dead wrong all right he thinks
he caught us making mistake there is
Humphrey Bogart's signature up in the
rafters and I have proof that's
legitimate take a look at this very rare
and authentic archival footage
hey mr. Bogart care to sign your name
sure thing fell I'd love to gee thanks
yeah I noticed that you crossed your T
there that's not like your normal
signature look fell give me a break I'm
riding on a beam
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Gogi bogey so the challenge still stands
all right still no one can catch us
unbelievable if you think you've spotted
an error on our show reported at team
koco.com slash ha ha I found an error
and we will sort it out right here on
the air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make chunk meat out of the
maestro all right we'll take a break
when we come back
[Applause]